[Música]
es el undécimo capítulo de una novela
que aún no tiene su final a la vista
cientos de miles de franceses marcharon
este jueves día laboral en el país galo
en las calles continúa el malestar por
la aprobación por decreto constitucional
de la controvertida Reforma pensional
del presidente Emmanuel macrón el
gobierno no quiere por ideología abrir
la puerta a otra solución que es la de
repartir la riqueza de manera diferente
y de cobrar impuestos a los más ricos
a lo largo de este jueves se registraron
choques en París nantes en
la capital gala incluso hubo un ataque
contra el que se considera es el
restaurante favorito del presidente
macrón mientras el mandatario completaba
un viaje a China desde su oficina
cargaron contra los sindicatos por las
infructuosas negociaciones desde estas
uniones con las que El Ejecutivo se
reunió el miércoles insisten en mantener
el llamado a tomarse las calles
esta reforma es percibida como brutal e
injusta por los trabajadores y las
trabajadoras y la juventud quienes han
entendido que van a tener que trabajar
más tiempo sin que el empresariado ni
los empleadores públicos se sometan a la
contribución
la nueva movilización se fijó para el 13
de abril en la víspera del día marcado
para que el consejo constitucional
decida sobre la aprobación definitiva de
la reforma pensional y la admisibilidad
de un pedido de referendo por parte de
la oposición
[Música]